it is hard to imagine that there could
be any such thing as excessive
intelligence
after all
most of the problems of the world and of
individual lives clearly come down to a
shortfall in cleverness
and a surfeit of impulsiveness
self-righteousness and cruelty
yet it seems that there could still be a
way of using our intelligence that cuts
us off from necessary encounters with
simple truths about us
with humdrum facts
with down-to-earth ideas and appetites
with unglamorous impulses and naive yet
profound speculations
if we can put it another way there might
be ways of being intelligent that could
at points render us distinctively stupid
there is a kind of person we can dub
over intellectual
whose cleverness can encourage them to
miss key points
it may make them blind to evident ideas
that are nevertheless significant
it may give them a permanent taste for
what is abstruse and infinitely subtle
at the expense of anything that doesn't
pass an exaggerated threshold of
convolution
they may neglect the chance of an
interesting conversation with a
six-year-old because their associations
of intelligence are rigidly affixed to
scholarlyness
or they might disdain the offer of a
walk with their aunt because she left
school at 16 and has never taken an
interest in politics
their intricate minds may end up
misunderstanding reality
which comprises both ludwig victonstein
and hot baths
emmanuel kant and dancing queen
aristotle and orange and polenta cake
the over-intellectual may spend hours
passing the distinction between free
will and determinism
they may devote themselves to
interpreting maxwell's theory of
electricity and magnetism
and yet still being novice when it comes
to explaining their heart or avoiding
assault
true cleverness means resorting to
complexity when and only when it is
called for
and otherwise keeping room open for ways
of speaking and thinking that are
appropriately basic and visceral
it may be highly fitting to use riddles
and jargon when one is dealing with the
operations of a nuclear reactor or the
nature of time at the edges of the
universe
but it becomes a particular form of
obtuseness to remain in such a register
when unpicking issues in relationships
or family dynamics
those who are properly intelligent can
accept that there are central truths
about every life
that should be expressed in the language
of a child
it is an achievement enough to sound
very clever
it may be an even greater one to know
where and when to remain heart
stirringly simple
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you